رد رن على الاتهامات الغربيه لطهران
بتزويد روسيا بميئات المسيارات قال مسؤول
ايراني رفيع للجزيره ان تلك الاتهامات لا
اسس لها واضاف المسؤول الايراني ان اصرار
واشنطن على ربط المسيارات الايرانيه بحرب
اوكرانيا يهدفه شيطانه ايران طهران
وتصويرها هدفا او طرفا في هذه الحرب اشير
الى ان محاولته واشنطن شيطانه علاقات
بلاده الدفاعيه مع روسيا تهدف لتحقيق
مكاسب سياسيه كما اشار الى ان تطوير بلاده
الشراكه الدفاعيه والعسكريه مع روسيا ليس
امرا جديدا وليس موجها ضد اي دوله
هذا وكاله الخارجيه الايرانيه قد نفت
الاتهامات بتزويد طهران لموسكو بالمسيرات
واكدت بانها اتهامات عاريه من الصحه وقالت
الخارجيه الايرانيه ان ارسال الاسلحه من
بريطانيا وحلفائها الى اوكرانيا ادى الى
اطاله ابد الحرب وتاخير التوصل الى حل
سلمي
وقالت الخارجيه الايرانيه انها استدعت
السفير البريطانيه في طهران على خلفيه ما
وصفته بدعمده باعمال الشغب ومواقفها التي
تعتبر تدخل في شؤون ايران الداخليه
هذا مكانا جيمس كليفر لوزير الخارجيه
البريطاني قال فيما وصفها بالاتفاقات
الدنيئه بين ايران وروسيا تهدد الامن
العالمي واضاف كليفر لان ايران تعتبر الان
تعتبر الان واحدا من اكبر داعمي روسيا
عسكريا حيث ارسلت اليها مئات الطائرات
المسيره واوضح ان روسيا تقدم دعما عسكريا
وفنيا لنظام الايراني في المقابل ما يزيد
من تهديد طهران لشركائنا في المنطقه
وللامن الدوليه وكشف كليفرلي ان لندن تتفق
مع تقيم واشنطن بان الدعم الايراني للجيش
الروسي سوف ينمو في الاشهر القادمه